that is just an objectionable thing for
Humanity to do right it's not the worst
thing we've ever done but it's part of
our worst
[Music]
instincts hey what's going on everybody
for first we Feast I'm Sean Evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by John Oliver
yeah we are he's the PE body
award-winning host of Last Week Tonight
with John Oliver show that's won more
than two dozen Emmy since premiering
2014 catch new episodes Sunday nights on
HBO at 11:00 Eastern with past episodes
canonized rather conveniently right here
on YouTube John Oliver welcome to the
show thank you Sean um I was going to I
was going to say it's a pleasure to be
here but let's not start with me lying
right into right right you know that's
how we build the trust just have to be
honest exactly let's build an immediate
connection my instinct says this is
going to go very very
[Music]
badly
let Stockholm syndrome
[Music]
commence I'll be
honest that was hotter than I wanted the
first one to
be
[Music]
I would not say great at this point I
would say uh-oh we're working with a
different Spectrum mhm than my face is
used to we're going to put a number to
it today all right okay yeah all right
do you have an all-time favorite missuse
of HBO resources for a bit on Last Week
Tonight I mean I love misusing their
resources there is there's almost
nothing in life that makes me happier
than doing something I think they're
going to be a little bit mad at so yeah
we we bought Russell Crow's jock strap I
was going to give people context I don't
know if you really need any uh it was
from the movie Cinderella Man um and so
we bought it and we sent it to uh one of
the last remaining Blockbusters in
Alaska I think that then shut down I
believe it was then sent to the last the
actual last Blockbuster which I think is
in Oregon I think that's where Russell
Crow Cinderella Man jockstrap is right
now the Smoky Jay I don't like the name
at all
[Music]
H not horrible right I think you were uh
kind of Jarred a little bit by the first
one you know but that would be like you
know you're a football fan right that's
like you got out on the pitch you took a
bump and now you're settled into the
game you know yes which football are we
talking about there I'm talking about
round football you know because I'm a
host I'm hospitable you know what I'm
saying John yes oh Pitch Pitch with the
giveaway pitch I didn't even that really
was hospitable you said Pitch and I
didn't internalize that you were being
gracious yes I love I love football very
much and that you're right that felt
like this one gave me a nudge mhm this
one I don't feel nudges anymore cuz
you're in the game baby cuz I'm in the
game I'm all about the game so when we
had Lis th on the show last year he said
that his britishness works as like a
superpower for getting American subjects
to just reflexively trust him does that
align at all with your own experience it
does I mean he's a brilliant interviewer
right in fact I thought I was going to
meet him it was when I was working at
The Daily Show it was a producer there
had worked with him and they they'd set
up something for my birthday and so he
just needed to get me upstairs and he
said Lou th is here do you want to meet
him and I was so excited and then I ran
in and it was just a surprise birthday
party for me and I had to really reverse
engine Oh I thought I was meeting Louis
THU not this an emotional sort of short
cir this isn't what I wanted you're not
him you're celebrating my birth that's
not what I was
[Music]
promised the Stella fuzz funky hot sauce
yeah the names are getting fun yeah
aren't they
though actually like that this is going
to be the
moment I remember somewhere over here
has the good
times from breaking your nose in a Civil
War reenactment to hiding from security
during the 2008 Republican National
Convention what stands out in your
memory as being the most heroing
experience you had as a Daily Show field
reporter they were all pretty harrowing
I think um I mean that was one of my
first experien in America was breaking
my nose it probably made me realize that
I was in the right place to work it was
a dream come true to come and work for
John Stewart that was my first
interaction with the US Healthcare
System no notes by the way Sean works
great um to get back to the office and
hear them playing that clip again and
again and laughing so hard it kind of
made me think oh you're more concerned
about the joke than me I think I think
this is where I belong you found a home
yeah Los centes fair
day again I feel
like I'm being hit in the face with a
setup jab right right it's the lead left
that is hitting me but that's not the
fist I'm worried about you know what
just roll with it because we're moving
forward you know what I mean every step
is a sauce that's out of the way you
know what I'm saying so you just take it
if you got kind of a freebie just take
it don't apologize for it enjoy it these
are the good times is a sauce out of the
way if that isn't a piece of merch if
you don't have that on a t-shirt Chris
run it and you're leaving money on the
table for the uninitiated what's magical
about the Edinburgh festival and how do
you think it shaped you as a
standup I mean the magical thing about
it and you know that word is overused
but it to me there is a really magic to
it is that it's not curated like so many
other festivals um are you're invited to
come so that you maintain a certain
standard the beauty of Edinburgh is that
kind of quality control doesn't exist so
it's just absolute freefor all of
artistic Mayhem and that can produce
things as great and as terrible as you
would imagine it is the greatest place I
miss it so much every year it's the best
and you know it seems like bombing is
almost a part of the process it's like a
right of passage when you do that is
there a set that you look back on and
think of as like a comedy nightmare
there was a gig in Edinburgh I I I'm not
sure if it still goes uh it started at
1: in the morning it was called late in
life and it was a bare pit so it's um
starts at 1
notoriously aggressive uh there was one
time i' bombed already very fun
uh and then a comedian had gone on after
me had done really well and he was
getting an encore and as he came off we
agreed that it would be funny if I took
his Encore so I then went back on and a
guy smashed a glass a beer glass on the
table in front of me and he said if you
tell another joke I'm going to stab you
and I said to him this this anger in you
it just can't be about me and he said it
really
is and you know that's one of the
happiest memories of edin Brook I have
is have a guy saying I you are going to
compel me to commit an act of
violence that is how much I object to
what you think is f yes in that violence
it's not me that's right it's you that's
right it I promise this is you problem
your implication is there are other
things happening in my life there there
aren't I have a stable happy life you've
turned it upside down and you must be
[Music]
stopped queso sin queso
I don't know if
um if that's a collab i'
encourage but another level of heat but
it seems like you're kind of on top of
it you know I was a little nervous with
the first one but it does seem like
you've caught a rhythm here
John oh yeah yeah I mean if you if you
if you're asking my confidence gone up
no I'm still at thinking that's smart
that's smart you know where people get
into trouble is when they get
overconfident at this point you know
that is not possible I we're five in I
think we all know where this is
heading you have a quote that I found
interesting where you said the problem
is the loudest journalism in America is
generally Sayan the least can you
unpackage that with our show no one in
their right mind would try and do a show
about prison health no one no one wants
to hear about that but they should know
about it and so we're going to force
feed it to them and we're in a very very
lucky position cuz we don't don't have
the commercial pressures that other
certain news outlets do have so we are
lucky to be able to follow whatever um
whatever interest us and force feed it
to people but they can't or won't do
that and so you are left with yeah kind
of yammering Talking Heads who um on on
TV who are are really not talking about
much and that the problem with being in
a Perpetual election cycle and we're in
election year now never really feels
like the elction year stops that's the
problem right and that takes out all the
air from a room cuz you're just talking
about people but candidates like
politicians whereas policies are much
more important than politicians um but
we are focused on the personalities and
that's easy to do but it's not the most
important
stuff Bourbon and maple think they're
concealing what the third world is
promising now what's nice about
this is I do think you get a little
Maple up front you know the first thing
you catch is maple mhm yep then what
happens yep is there's this tail on
Maple
delivered bourbon not detected but I
appreciate the idea is there and then
the reaper says
actually I'm the star of the show that's
right I'm the captain now I I am the
guest at this party who is going to
dictate the
evening are you someone who finds
comfort and the stress and tension of an
adversarial interview it almost seems
like it would be like a prerequisite for
anyone who went through the Daily Show
School of
broadcasting yeah that's a really good
question yes is the answer and I can't
really square that with who I am as a
person there is something where my heart
rate goes down and I don't feel what
they are feeling so yeah I don't I I
can't really explain why I don't mind it
and I'm and I'm drawn to hostile
interviews um yeah they it brings out a
side of me that I don't particularly
like but it is
there okay the forbidden fruit all
right mhm same with
me Yep this is a jump
um that wasn't
fun that's not an experience I'm going
to look back upon with remember the good
old days remember the good old days John
remember funky's hot
sauce oh funky hot sauce with your
Stella fuzz and your fun little cartoon
fox we had fun didn't
we if I went to a Liverpool match at
anfield what's one chant and one
obscenity I'd need to know most L chant
you should probably know it's basically
Mo Sal Mo Sala running down the wing Sal
la la la la the Egyptian king that's it
I think I got that yeah you can do it
it'll be great my my kids knew that song
before they knew anything else if right
now if I say to them mo they'll just
even if they're a different room they'll
say one in down the wing that's right
kids that's right where does nailing
that free kick in uh sea when you're
covering the where does that fall on
your list of career accomplishments it
has to be up
there it is so depressingly high I I'm
genuinely embarrassed to say how much it
meant to me scoring that free kick in my
head I'm seeing a wall of like four or
five like six foot guys and it bending
all the way and then kissing the bottom
of the crossbar and going in it it went
in and I just started
running absolute Joy Hing through my
body and yeah it's one of the best
sporting moments of my life and I think
and the whole thing was kind of set up
as a joke right it wasn't a game he
might have let it in but um the fact I
scored I think a serviceable free kick
in Soo is
spectacular I mean I've been putting
this off but I guess there's uh there's
nowhere to run no no all right
okay this you know almost
immediately
holy [__]
[__]
mhm
who
M and I'm not going to lie to you John
it's just going to kind of build from
here a little bit oh that's good to know
yeah you know I just want to be
transparent good yeah
thanks I'm pretty I'm pretty angry at
that yeah no I get it are you about to
smash a glass please don't stab me John
it's not about you Sean I know it's not
about you
um so how many of these have you had in
your life I'll estimate 3155 times
you're going to die aren't you but I
made it so far you know what I mean
maybe I'm actually sure you made it so
far it feels like the science hasn't
caught up to what you're doing to your
body yet I'm one W you know this feels
yeah this feels like the kind of stomach
version of CTE for football players yeah
yeah they're going to cut your stomach
open and realize oh yeah you can't in a
medical journal actually isn't okay um
and then just be careful around your
eyes you know what I mean cuz you have
it on your fingers I can see the tears
coming so I'm just be very careful be
very careful and you know what while you
endure that I know that you spend over a
month preparing to systemically dissect
all these complex issues on your show
but after the bomb I think it just be
kind of fun to get your totally
unprepared raw take on some hot topics
so I'll just throw just to be clear
everything that I just said I don't like
you want me to do now what I like is you
know considered I wish the news did it
more take your time right right render a
coherent opinion make sure you back it
up don't shoot from the hip what you're
saying is the walls are closing in and
I've pulled the guns The Muppets The
Muppets yes Muppets okay I love the
Muppets so much in many ways crazy this
might sound we've kind of modeled the
show around the Muppets um those big
things that they
uh
did the you know the big things The
Muppets did I don't know what I'm
talking about now I love I love I love
um puppets
Sean um love Island this feels like my
Vietnam I shouldn't have got into this
and I've got no good way out yeah and
you the the Napalm is
you could feel it in the room sorry you
were saying love Island love Island love
island is um Britain Britain's ID um it
is you take us if you take us at our
best with Monty Python I'm afraid you
must also take us at our worst with love
Island George Santos George Santos Joel
Santos in office I kind of turned on it
seemed like at the start this guy has no
place in politics towards the end I
thought I kind of love this guy he's
this part of me I not a part that I
particularly respect one TR mut thinking
I love well now what's he doing he's got
a mystery baby sounds right come on
George what do you got next felt like he
was his whole time in office he was get
produced by Andy Cohen in a way that I
genuinely liked de bom beond Insanity to
bom behind Insanity that is just an
objectionable thing for Humanity to do
right it's not the worst thing we've
ever done but it's part of our worst
instincts it's really terrible but
you've deserve survived it and it's
behind us you never be able to take that
away from you say that I couldn't say
I'd be completely surprised if I woke up
in a hospital room now and they said oh
no
you you blacked out after queso sin
queso so what what the [__] is
this mat SOS hot sauce and it's a monkey
in a top hat which I do
like is this going to be worse no
nothing's going to be as bad let you
just say it won't be fun but it will not
be worse yeah that's a perfect
description of
this this is not fun but not worse why
am I still eating it I don't know I'm
following along with you how why on
Earth I'm eating more of
that maybe you'll like it you know yeah
there's a tension that you find
comforting yeah exactly there a deeply
selfworth of you deserve it you deserve
the monkey in the Hat spitting its
metallic Venom At You of the odd jobs
that you worked before TV which do you
remember fonder shoveling oats as a
factory worker or working the phones for
someone who trafficked and stolen
kitchen
appliances I did do both of those things
there was
one there was one OD job that I had that
one summer when I was a kid I was a
cashier at like a independent little
Supermarket it was when there were price
stickers on things you had to input it
to make the day go interestingly I kind
of had kind of dynamic pricing system
for people so the people like I would
overcharge some people I could
undercharge others so it was it was
basically operating my own kind of
Taxation system on I know that you've
you you came up in a nice car bad news
these beans are going to cost more than
you
thinks this woman comes in with four
kids these beans are going to be half
pric for you and it it made it work so
it was it was like my perfect version of
making um you know the world you're like
a Robin Hood you're you're a cashier
Robin Hood yeah that was a fun job
though
yeah all right John all right wow okay
so what's
this
oh what the hell we've come this
far do you do is that all right let me
see yeah that's generous okay i' maybe
do one of these do yeah hit it with one
of those I'm at a point to be honest
where um I'm not sure I can feel
anything anymore I feel like a spice so
we're on the other side we're on the
other side yeah well cheers John what
won Salo we did
it
mhm I mean and again like the last
one not fun
but it's all behind us yeah it kind of
doesn't matter it doesn't matter anymore
right this resets your body's
expectations of what is allowable the
hard part's over John we just have one
more question for you and to do it I
want to kick it back to when we had
Trevor Noah in the show okay and he said
that the parting words that he received
from John Stewart when taking over the
show was yeah I'm leaving because I'm
old and angry and you're young and happy
so enjoy it while it lasts is someone
who's marinated in news headlines and
commentary for nearly two decades how do
you think your work has shaped your view
of the future like do you think that
you've been permanently fossilized in a
kind of cynicism or does your experience
give you like an oddly optimistic look
at what's
ahead a really good question
I think to a certain
extent yes but not beyond that I think
when the deeper you look into these
stories the more flawed you realize
things are systemically but the more you
encounter people work incredibly hard to
change things like clockwork at some
point during a story I'll leave my
office and go into Tim's office who I
run the show
with and we'll say burn it down just
burn everything to the ground cuz it
feels like things so bad in a story only
Flames are going to
purify the hell that we've built for
ourselves but you do then work through
that much like this shitty hot sauce uh
to realizing
that in lie of even as you're waiting
for major change that you think might
not come incremental changes possible
and value people do it was that coherent
I'm not sure what I just said nailed the
Dismount John Oliver look at you taking
on at you the wings of death living to
tell the tale like hitting that free
kick in suo that's right right at the
top baby kiss the crossbar went in I'm
running
goal and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
I think what what I like about this in
general I think is is you know a lot
people complain about the filibuster
that a price should be paid for
something you know that they say that
you shouldn't just be able to say f bus
you should stand on your feet for 18
hours and go to the have to wear a
diaper this feels like a vers of that
for promotion doesn't it there should be
a price to pay that's what we thought
that's that's literally the thesis of
the show you got a B minus movie you
want to sell earn it earn it dance for
me um um I I I don't have much to say
our show is back on um February the 18th
I'm pretty sure that's the accurate date
can I plug other people's things yeah go
ahead um best book I've read for a while
was Patrick rad and Keef say nothing
have you read that no your
recommendation
fantastic i' would recommend you read
say nothing by Patrick Ren Keef and yeah
I'm not Patrick Ren Keith even though if
you told me right now that I was I
wouldn't
argue
wow that's the hot one's experience yeah
and it is an experience isn't it I can
see why people feel closer to you at the
end of this if we traa band because you
exactly you go through a common
experience come over here and give me a
hug it's like it's like we've been
through battle together thanks so much
mate really nice to meet you it was
really
fun hey what's going on hot ones fans
this is Sean Evans thank you so much for
watching today's episode and if you
would like to get the taste of hot ones
delivered right to your door well I have
good news for you the season 23 hot ones
10 pack is available now heatness.com
heatness.com that's heatness.com to get
your hands on the season 23 hot ones
lineup milk not included ice cream
highly recommended and
remember be careful around the
eyes